[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we host webinars every
Tuesday my name is Tom McGrath and I'm
joined by fang lu software engineer from
the cloud composer team and today we'll
be talking about cloud composer and how
it orchestrates containers and even more
you can ask questions at any time on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them let's get started so our
agenda today will be looking at an
overview of composer and Apache airflow
well look at how to use cloud composer
we'll also see what's new in the GA
release Fang will provide an awesome
demo we'll also look at some dag
examples of advanced concepts and then
from there our next steps in roadmap and
where to find out more so what is cloud
composer as a starting point let's
understand the fit for cloud composer by
looking at the state of the industry for
a moment there's a lot of data today I
think we can all agree about that but
how much data exactly well IDC estimates
163 zettabytes of data that's 163
billion terabytes will exist by 2025
that's a lot right thing yeah yeah so
organizations are heavily investing in
public cloud and currently are planning
to adopt public cloud strategies but at
the same time they're going to continue
with some of their own premises
investments as well so it's very clear
that a hybrid cloud strategy is
necessary in this environment with the
need for a hybrid strategy and before a
cloud composer there are a few ways of
managing workflows across systems or
even on the Google cloud platform and I
think it's fair to say these are not the
best at all no not at all I wrote a lot
of those stacks it's a pain yeah I don't
want a solution yeah exactly
even just creating and scheduling cron
jobs and managing those or even going to
the other end of the spectrum of
creating your own orchestration engine
it's just a lot of work with a high cost
of ownership absolutely yeah yeah so the
cloud composer team rightly thought it
should be easy to create schedule and
modder robust portable workflows that
work inside
outside of Google cloud platform for a
holistic workflow lifecycle so all these
items highlighted in blue are key and
critical for workflow it's more than
scheduled and just let it run or any one
of these items it's all of them together
so we're aiming to provide it or gonna
provide organizations a solution that
covers them all and that's where cloud
composer fits which was just made
generally available nice work Fang in
team thank you yep and so it's just made
available inside of Google cloud
platform and the short version of cloud
composer is that it's managed Apache
airflow so Y Cloud composer and and GCP
integration orchestrate your full
pipeline through cloud composer and we
want to make sure that we surpris
supported those hybrid and multi cloud
environments that we're seeing in the
marketplace where these things are just
important to everyone we also want to be
very easy not have to wrangle with lots
of code be able to leverage Python to be
able to orchestrate these workflows and
not have to write a lot of that code
that's necessary but also keep it open
source we want people to contribute and
be part of the larger community right
exactly yeah so a common question is
well what's the difference between a
airflow manage and running it on some
VMs well what the team has done is
they've created a seamless and
integrated experience with GCP so it's
not standalone and does not feel like a
standalone product security I am audit
logging all those things are baked in so
it accident feels like an actual cloud
product it's also easy to use when
things go is not expected within your
workflows and so stackdriver is
integrated for that exact reason and we
make it easy to manage the deployment
with studying environment variables and
maintaining your Python packages some of
you might not be familiar with air flow
or may have just heard of it so we're
really excited about it and we want you
to see why it's so exciting so air flow
is currently incubating as an Apache
Software Foundation project it's
actually been around for a few years as
a leading open-source PAC
to create and schedule workflows so all
the workflows in it our code with Python
and they're highly approachable and you
can do a lot with it including some
programmatic workflows will actually
look through some quick simple examples
and you'll see how easy it is to work
with the code in Python for air flow so
the strengths of air flow in the
open-source community we wanted to bring
those together with the strengths of
Google cloud platform as you can see on
the right hand side Google cloud
platform we're great at running
infrastructure creating services adding
layers of security audit ability and
containing costs but there is no
workflow an orchestration solution
airflow on the other hand had really
strong has really strong workflow
orchestration and connectors inside of
outside of GCP description language
defined api's and so on so we wanted to
bring them together but also we wanted
to contribute back to the community and
a great example of that is the
kubernetes pod operator which we'll
cover later on in the demo
so within airflow the key concepts all
workflows our graphs series of tasks and
a task can fit into a graph it could be
as simple as a bash script to tell the
time of course they get plenty more
complicated from their graphs can have a
series of tasks and halves are basically
a step for example maybe I want to run a
sequel query or a bigquery query and
export that to Google Cloud Storage
there's also the concept of a sensor a
boolean check on a step that waits until
something has completed when true it
precedes so we can orchestrate our
workflows very seamlessly using these
air flow concepts with the dag views
inside of air flow it makes it very easy
to understand your workflow and its
properties including any bottlenecks or
errors and really what this allows you
to do is chart a path to higher
reliability of your orchestration
workflows so in terms of additional air
flow functionality can
affections there's all sorts of
different connections from airflow into
other systems we talked a lot about
logging and being able to see what's
going on with an airflow but also SL A's
whether or not you're actually meeting
those or not there's also the capability
of passing values between tasks so lots
of interesting advanced functionality
and usually there's some questions of
can airflow do do X and usually the
answer is yes ya know you may often
means that you may need to either the
existing operators you don't often you
have to sort of try to come out with
your solution that tends to be hard but
it's still possible yeah it's a very
flexible platform yep yeah in terms of
Google cloud platform there's a core set
of error flow support built in so data
flow connectors bigquery cloud storage
to name a few and support is actually
expanding with each airflow release and
this is happening within the airflow
team but also within the Google cloud
team so what about support outside of
GCP really important so for example I
can run bash commands I can call other
public clouds I can connect into JIRA or
even slack for example to send
notifications and interact with those
tools and there's so many more under
development so made so much support for
non-google things mm-hmm fully usable
with an airflow and this cloud composer
as well so in terms of some of the new
cloud composer features it's been made
available in a few new regions stack
driver logging has been very much
expanded which we'll see within the demo
there's also been the inclusion of
additional I am roles and then
additional future editions in air flow
so the kubernetes pod operator brought
in park' source format and also location
selection for cloud dataflow jobs so
more and more functionality being added
in with called composer and I think you
can see that with this ga release yeah
yeah so what does using cloud composer
look like so
you create a composer environment within
a project each environment is a managed
deployment of Apache airflow so you
don't have to worry about the
installation and some other typical
administrative tasks exactly that's the
why we created a composer to start with
definitely right that's that takes a
little bit of uplift right thing yeah
yeah and projects can contain more than
one environment and so these integrate
with multiple different services cloud
storage to manage your workflows
stackdriver to understand what's
happening within the environment and
then of course we're securing the
environment with iam which we'll explain
in a moment so fun functionality-wise
these different methods of accessing
cloud composer all all the same one of
the things that's interesting to point
out though is with the SDK we've
actually made it convenient to manage
composer and air flow both from the same
command line tool so with G cloud having
that installed I can then run my airflow
commands against my environment
exactly isn't that cool that's awesome
that's awesome that you guys are able to
pull that together you have the the
tunnel and the commands just flow right
through all right you can manage
everything in the same place super easy
so when we look at the architecture it's
really a collection of GCP resources
so you'll notice off the bat that
there's two projects there's a customer
project and then there's the tenant
product project the former is visible
the customer project you see that
running within your cloud console the
tenant project is actually managed by
GCP so that was a design decision made
because of apache excuse me air flows
micro service feel do you want comment
on that really quick thing oh yeah so
they are you know I all flow
constructive service made up of fuel
components that have web server to have
scheduler they have worker sort of
different micro service component needs
to run a bad fits into different DCP
services for example like with web
server naturally kinds of fit into the
GAE domain right
likewise for schedule and worker you
know
sometimes those need to communicate you
need to have the right you know it's
good that we can fit those into a TCP
service that provides communication from
grown up and coburn ID you know google
kübra ad clusters will be a good place
to host that some of those outflow
resources absolutely and being able to
scale up and scale down is not necessary
right one of the things I like about the
design too is that when we look at the
airflow database that was obscured away
in a tenant project so it could be
secured down because when we think about
connections to other systems we don't
want that those connection details to
get out we want those locked down and
secured away and by keeping it away in
the tenant project that that's taken
care of basically right so we really
really really try to restrict the access
to or your outflow minor data's database
because it contains a lot of connection
credentials real but you know at the
same time I realized that sometimes you
do need to get database access that is
entirely possible by downing meaning
from the kubernetes engine that he used
to run your outflow deployment right
exactly and one of the things I also
think that's really cool is that when
you think about the things they're
inside the tenant project those are
things that don't necessarily need to be
touched right they can just operate and
run and that's all well and good from a
customer's perspective that's right yeah
and the other thing I like to is that in
terms of locking down the access to the
airflow web server you leverage the
identity aware proxy so the user can
just sign in using their I am
credentials and getting access that way
they don't have to actually like do some
sort of proxy tunneling or anything like
that true yeah that's that's the reason
why we decided to put this you know kind
of project and also put it behind the
IEP so that is why he's always
accessible to you without all the
proxying setup one more thing I want to
mention is that the reason why we put
things in tenon projects so that we can
hide all the IEP details from customers
you know you don't have to learn I a P
in order to use composer
everything's we manage e for you that's
an excellent point
excellent point and then of course when
it comes to leveraging down
which are basically your workflows and
logs and plugins that's all done through
cloud storage and then of course logging
goes into stack driver and we'll see
that deploying a dag is super easy just
copy a file that you says that you need
to do yeah it's so easy moving files to
GCS so no problems there
so let's see what an actual workflow
looks like at a very high level it's
basically a collection of tasks with
inter dependencies and relationships
so basically tasks associated with
workflows dependencies wait until the
data's available in GCS for example and
then start my bigquery job or trigger
something right that file is actually
available within HDFS let's copy it into
GCS from there so these are really the
building blocks of workflows and airflow
and then of course maybe when my job
completes then I want to notify my users
on slack so they know that the most
up-to-date data and information is
available to them yeah so airflow tags
are effectively Python files with five
main sections and we'll cover each of
those in turn so import right step one
import from the airflow system a dag or
directed acyclic graph is basically
another way of saying workflow so we
import the operators to be used in the
workflow for example the bigquery
operator you can see there on the fourth
line and then from there we can trigger
rules
to specify the inter task relationships
then the arguments are defined so we
might have some default dag arguments
and that's a convenient thing for air
flow but if there's common arguments
that you want to leverage instead of
specifying those for each air flow task
you actually specify those at the
beginning of your workflow and then pass
them in automatically via the air flow
dag model I think that's super cool yeah
yeah saves a lot of boilerplate Cody
yeah workflow yeah absolutely lots of
flexibility yeah yeah so in terms of
setup you basically give it a name so
in this case demo dag a scheduled
interview in interval and also default
arguments very simple straightforward
easy to understand and then we define
the tasks so here you can see that we
have a big query operator and also a big
created GCS operator so within the big
crew operator we're running a big query
query that will export the results to an
a new dataset and you can see we're
specifying the name of the table within
bigquery
but then we also have the bigquery to
cloud storage operator which is
exporting that new data set to cause
storage once again easy integration very
simple and easy to understand plus the
CODIS not hot to read oh no absolutely
not
yeah this is this is simple and
straightforward stuff and that's that's
the that's the purpose yeah yeah so in
terms of ordering the tasks can be
ordered based on completion dependencies
one thing must finish before the other
for example my air flow commits query
the query that runs that creates my
dataset must finish before I want to
export that data to GCS it makes sense
it's that easy so at this point we're
gonna switch to the demo thing is going
to present that for us so take it away
fame thanks Tom so so far we have been
talking about all the nice thing about a
composer and now let's see how we put
everything in action we mentioned that
you know to got a things started the
first thing you probably want to do is
go to there are few places we mention
about console we mention about a call
SDK here we're just where you will use
console as a way to times you and how to
play with composer similar functionality
can be achieved using cloud SDK most of
case you know what you want to do is go
you know once you are in they call
composer paging console say you want to
create a composing environment click the
clip click the create and that leads you
to the quit page here you can specify
your name say hey demo
and then you can specify all the
arguments or all the properties of that
environment I'm gonna walk you through
some of the configuration options that
you might have
you can obvious specify the region where
you want to create your composing
environment you could also specify
things like a machine-type number of
knows all scope and also want to
highlight one thing for beta isolation
and production we was allowed to space
for service account you used to run the
composing environment so you don't have
to use the sort of generic
key for the compute engine service
account you can use any service account
at your choice very cool yeah scroll
down a little bit there section is about
some airflow configuration properties
you know our flow yourself comes with a
long list of configurations how many
would you say there are if you had to
guess I think it's probably 100 plus
configuration options but you are not
going to use off those say there's some
common ones I'd say if you want to
decide how soon you want to reload your
diet for that small something you care
because every time you make a change and
you want an outflow to pick up that
change quickly so that's something you
can come fake moving down we was having
environmental variables those are the
ones if you want to send an email right
now composer accounts by together with
send great email support so you would
config a composer environment by just
adding two environment variables like
centigrade mail from and send agree API
key those who all get to set up with
email capabilities excellent labels you
know if you want to basically
conveniently navigate through composing
environments and even across allergies
to be resources you can always use
labels you know attach to environments
to our theory analyst labels you will be
able to get your environment I probably
can escape the part of creating a
composing environment reason because it
may take 10 plus min it's not because
the reason is we need to create an app
engine and takes a while for the app
engine to get ready so let's assume that
you already have that you environment
ready okay yeah perfect so let's go back
so we have composed a demo environment
Korea beforehand
you know once you have the environment
ready you can go in and inspect the
various properties of that environment
here you get the overview like how many
number of nodes service account or scope
and you also get to see that two
important things here one is the host al
flow web UI the second thing is the
Jesus packet they all flow web UI allows
you to inspect workflows and then the
Jesus packet is really for you to upload
and make changes to your tax files next
time so now let's go and take a look at
it web server host your web server yeah
let's see it in action
yeah so as I mentioned earlier the web
server is hosted in je protected by aap
if you first log into this page you will
ask you for your Google credentials
logging Evoque can be your gmail account
or it can be you know you can also have
problematic access to the web server by
using service account both ways are
possible and once you are in the outflow
web UI you could start to inspect the
various workflows you have submitted for
example like earlier we have Tom walks
you through the Beco demo so we can
inspect and check a few details of that
you have a few tasks those tasks a
change in some other not very fancy
understand it's like really like a
linear chain of tasks but you can create
as complicated workflows as you want so
for the timeline is really try to
connect you back to the example you have
just seen right you have you create a
data side you run PQ query and then you
export the data to Jesus yeah I've
definitely seen customers who are
running air flow where their diagrams or
their graph views easily take up the
whole screen exactly this is this is of
course a very simplistic example but it
shows the idea of what's possible with
an airflow right right yeah and then
there are various views of that it will
work flow there's the graph view you got
a tree view
and then personally I myself also find
the honestly that's I again share a view
I'm sorry this one she was the timeline
this is the gun chair view you know this
allows you to put all your task
completion in you know single place you
will be able to say hey when a pass
guests are there when where you spend
most time on a specific task so this is
really helpful because then we can
basically I look at everything in one
place and understand where the
bottlenecks are exactly yeah and then
you can decide you know from that point
how should you optimize your workflow
pipeline got it yeah
let's go back and then I go to the home
page and see us actually start a
workflow run that's here you can easily
trigger workflow run from the i/o flow
web page once our workflow drawings
created you see the workflow runs the
status that you would have a one run
says running and then I'm fortunate you
have to probably have to refresh the
page from time to time so that you can
see tasks be moved from various stages
guys so here we have seen that we have a
task that's right now in running state
it's probably done processing but you
can go back to inspect you know it's
another one if you go to the graph view
you can see the various state of the
mover state of the task and sometimes if
I curious to understand the logs that's
produced by the pass you can always go
inspect here and that's a common request
just across a lot of a lot of users want
to be able to see the logs and see
what's going on especially from air flow
when it's touching so many different
systems exactly and then often sometimes
when you have task failures that's
probably that locks become most useful
so we understand sometimes a failure may
come out from when a follow-me not
actually happened with seeing out flow
think about you have a process crash you
have a container restart that those
events are not uncommon in kubernetes we
provide a stack driver locks so that you
know
I always kept somewhere even for the
logs that happen outside outflow yeah
very helpful for debugging and seeing
what's actually going on right yeah so
if you go to our stuff you have a login
page we actually have that Acadia called
composers stop there you can navigate
there try to figure out like which which
environment which region and which
environment you have your outflow
environment creative you can select
those environment and then once you have
selecting them you will be able to see
all the logs pertaining to your
environment we try to classify those
logs into a few categories we have our
flow scheduled logs worker locks that
helps you to better manage your logs
one more thing we have added to the air
flow worker locks is we do allows you to
filter locks by bag ID task ID and
execution date you will quickly help you
to navigate to the specific tasks you're
looking for and then you can really
narrow your way through the logs as
opposed to looking at everything right
otherwise you're just saying as
continuous stream of locks on your offer
worse that those locks you may mix will
form each like from concurrent pass of
course it works because chances are you
probably have multiple different DAGs
protect perhaps even sub tags which
we'll get into it can easily become
quite complicated exactly yet this
removes all that complication yeah
that's that's how we saw that you know
how we could expect you ever log in
useful for you for giving out flow decks
awesome yeah moving bag which we saw
notice that the BQ demo workflow has
completed successfully you know you see
that yeah it's not showing that it was
running that's more in that second slot
there and there's no alerting right
sicko like right side you know it's
gonna run so yeah there's no red right
the other thing I also want to highlight
here is you know what G really is car
composer starts to support a coupon I
depart operator what I gives to you is
the flexibility for you to start and run
any container with jean-claude composer
you're not
and we for example in the past and pump
up you probably also got a lot of
similar questions now people ask hey I
have this dependency that it's not
really pipe I dependency how should i
you know install an imported pendency
into composer right yeah common question
how to configure customize adding some
custom code etc right now as things
become so easy anything you need to do
that
composer doesn't provide to you out of
the box just go and create a container
and then bring that a container to
workflow to composer and yeah I have a
very kind of simple container task let's
go just by in specula code a little bit
scroll down look here we have a couplet
power operator and then the image we run
is a very similar basically compute PI
nice yeah very cool yes but the nice
thing is I hope the things that I'm most
here is like really you can launch a
container and then the container image
can be anything so and then amazing for
extensibility right yeah and I actually
have some good news to share towards the
end of the session oh yeah more things
you can do is you know playing with
containers in car composer I'll make
some more about it for a few minutes
yeah I'm excited to hear about it yeah
in suspense so let's go back and then
again let's just do the same thing
that's just triggered I can run I just
wait to see everything action so we can
see it's running in that second slot
there I see the bright green circle yeah
yeah yeah we'll see the test gradual
move running to execution to completion
yeah perfect
yeah and then similarly I want to not
everyone know that you you can also
inspect container locks sometimes you
want to see your tasks logs of course
but then you also you may also want to
inspect the container locks that might
be useful for the debug like what's
happening in your container tasks nice
yeah
now we go the first task is done now
we're moving to a container task just
gave 10 15 seconds and we're doing out
back yeah there you go perfect it's just
you are Thanks there we go
you can't I don't she's team demo team
demo and you're gonna help I don't use
pixel a lot that's okay that's good
alright so the task is running we can
inspect the log that's one more thing I
want to highlight here which is a
perfect from this example sometimes
there might be some delay from outflow
when they when they try to collect logs
and display like in a web UI hmm because
you know you try to do things that
parish to save a lot of read read cost
but then with stackdriver you got logs
in real time so you don't have to wait
hours and tears imagine that you have
like a task that may take hours to
complete sure and then in the middle you
don't want to just wait a house be able
to see your logs I know you want to see
the logs right away you want to know
what's going on right yeah that's how
stage driver could come in a help so
that you can use speculaas in real time
awesome yeah okay let's just give you
some time for you to finish yeah well
while we're waiting for the demo to to
complete the other thing I also want to
mention things are very used to the
alpha web UI is it also gives you a
place for you to do retrigger dies but
also sometimes a common issue people run
into is that what if your dag ran into
an arrow state and you want to recover
from that arrow state things you can do
here is it's a be a manual but you know
it's the better for you to rerun the
Intel pipeline what you can do is by
delete or clear the field task and after
that you set your workflow status from
failed to running and then after the
workflow status change to running our
flow scheduler will be big will be able
to pickup and reschedule the previous
few tasks oh that's awesome yeah you can
pick up right from
exactly where the dagger left off
effectively right yeah ice we're also
trying to see how we can better automate
this instead of you always have to you
know perform its multi-step actions
yourself but it is like there's a way
for you to do that right now you know
absolutely absolutely
all right let's see how it's doing oh we
got that look at the very end there's
confused value of pi I was gonna say
that looks like pi yeah that is PI there
we go
correct yeah that that's pretty much
about a demo session so coming back I do
want to quickly recap what I have
described in what do we have discussed
in a demo we have create a composing
environment walks you through the
various configuration options we have
also shown you how you could inspect
your workflows our flow web UI and some
of the common tasks you could perform
using a flow web UI like triggering a
dagger and inspecting lot because and
sometimes you if you needed to get a
little bit more debugging of Xfinity you
know stack travel is well you can get
those information yeah I can definitely
see how through this demo we are
definitely taking care of and meeting a
lot of those challenges that we talked
about earlier right yeah so earlier we
mentioned that you know the way how our
flow expert acts is really code so with
code it opens up a lot of possibilities
for you to do more funny stuff here one
thing is you could template many cases
hey my work flow remains 99% unchanged I
only need to touch this single parameter
with each invocation of my diagram so
that's what's supporting in our flow was
templating you know just put whatever
parameter you need to temp to arise as a
encapsulate in ginger template and then
you can always instantiate that at a
background time awesome
yeah likewise you know if you are if
your dad is complicated think about you
have 500 you imagine that you have seen
some that example is like a few hundred
tasks at least I only imagine is so
tedious and probably also error-prone
for you too spicy
fighters tags or tasks one by one
yourself yes yes another way you can use
problematic attack generation where
everything's been done yet program
that's also one of the motivation behind
why we want to use programming languages
to define and a create Dax definitely
yeah I mean if I had to run a thousand
tasks of the same type that would just
be so tedious and you know with few
lines of code were able to do that right
yeah and then the last thing is you know
when it comes when you access grow speak
you want to modularity is you want to be
able to create a sub components out flow
has this concept called slap tag that
conveniently allows you to package a few
related tasks into a single sub deck and
no single subtag will be treated as if
they are single tasks in the master deck
that's awesome for reusability we've
been in here and also helps you to
organize hierarchy organize your tasks
in a hierarchical manner yeah yeah cool
so those are all the nice things you
could do using our flow using composer
using its programming model to define
the workflows some of the common
questions we have we have seen from our
customers can I install pipe app
packages we have just discussed that in
fact often more than that you could
install you know you can bring any
containers into a composer where you can
capture your dependencies there and
something that's interesting right is
when you do that when you place your
custom packages and custom code inside
that dag folder we actually recognize
that it's not actually a dagger doesn't
have those beginning dag statements that
we talked about earlier so we don't
actually try air flow doesn't pick it up
as a dag exactly yeah yeah that's cool
yeah
environment be also updated how to
upgrade it
I know roadmap not supported right now
but that's something we're working very
hard on yeah
we are composed to be offering more
reagents absolutely yes that's last time
we roadmap to expand composer to
possibly want with to merge more regions
by the end of the year and I think gia
is a good example of that right because
with the GA release it was then
available in two more regions right yeah
is that graphic
to create Dax we hear you yes yeah
working on your progress
we also want to make sure that you know
for the people who are not very
comfortable its programming although we
mentioned that you know alpha dog model
is really simple but still if you prefer
to use GUI for creating your tags that's
that's something we we see a value and
we're working on definitely can I choose
which version Python it's using composer
yes the supports going to be out soon
well you could specify whether you want
to use Python 2 or your Python 3 stay
tuned for that one
exactly alright some of those like a
more sort of like a broader scheme or
grand scheme of composer where we are
heading to you definitely want to see
more closed kubinashi and also
integrations as i mentioned i want to
save something at the end so here we are
the good news ago yeah soon we're gonna
make another release another release we
are going to allows you to create a GK
clusters deleted GK clusters and also
more importantly you can launch a
container in any GK clusters as long as
you have credentials that's awesome
think about that you know you know we
know like GK just promoted as g/km pram
where if you could orchestrate in a lawn
chair container in a remote cluster that
is hosted in yuan Prime eventually and
that gives you a convenient way for you
to build a hybrid orchestration in GCP
and it definitely makes sense when
there's definitely a number of customers
out there who don't want to continue to
leverage their on-prem investments
exactly yeah we see that so we think
like you know using GK I'm Prime might
be a good bridge to connect it to
definitely we're also looking at adding
more operators you know this year we
plan to add a another 20 or 30 G's to be
service-related operators in a sound
flow yeah very cool and resource usage
we definitely want to see more resources
lasticity I do need to the state aware
if you don't have any workflow executing
we should not you know you don't have to
pay anything now they will find out girl
that makes sense obviously you can
strain them out
needed or consumed based on usage and
based on needs exactly yeah yeah
definitely definitely consistent with
our managed services right yeah so with
all that being said how should I get
started today there are a few places you
can get a resources Apache outflow web
site has on a nice tutorials and
information covering the basics and some
of the examples they are in their
website but also we have a lot more
examples sample code how to and then
also the ways how to speed connect with
other GCP services in our you know Clark
imposed a cutback website cool with that
I'll be right yeah that's a wrap
so stay tuned for live Q&A and we will
be back with you in less than a minute
you
okay and we're back with some questions
the audience so I think about the first
questions that's pretty interesting is
what should I consider when deciding
whether to use cloud composure dataflow
and I think one of the key things there
is to clarify that cloud composure is
really more about orchestration and
making things happen within various
systems whereas dataflow is more for
processing and each yelling both
streaming and batch data moving into
some sort of data sink as necessary but
because of all those operators within
airflow and within available within
cloud composer I can see it's very easy
to say well gosh can I use cloud
composer as an ETL tool and that would
probably not be the best way to proceed
right the way out I would also call this
will be a composer will be a control
flow orchestration system where dataflow
is more you know obviously better data
century data processing focused yeah
definitely and so another question that
we received is what are some of the
reasons why it would be difficult to run
air flow myself and I should consider
leveraging cloud composer instead and I
think my understanding is that when it
comes time to install and run it and
things like that that can take a lot of
effort right yes
try to create a woman and yourself you
will see all the pings think about you
also need to upgrade dependences you
know especially if you try to run L
floor you know distributed environment
every time you try to install a package
you have to make sure that Gaussian
storing all your instances what services
got it yeah and think about how would
you be able to consistent distributed
acts to all your airflow instances makes
those are really tricky and hard to
manage by yourself problems big big
challenges right big challenges and how
much effort do you actually want to put
into making those things work right a
question yeah we really want you to be
able to say hey I want to use our flow
ten minutes after that you can start
using our flow by writing your first tag
we started worrying about how should I
use to my out flow on TCP or other call
providers makes sense and another
interesting one is there's a kubernetes
pot operator that would work with
flow right for running ML models and
things like that absolutely as I mention
now it's the gk pad operator that also
is the concern of resources and you
probably don't have to force to run your
container in the same cluster where you
run your composing environment you can
launch your tasks in any gk cluster
presumably some of the ones you marry
you might want to be using those who run
coop flows definitely and something I
think that's specifically interesting
with Q flow is if you think of all that
data engineering that goes into creating
a machine an ml model it's I mean cog
composer becomes a natural fit to
orchestrate those tests and right that's
really awesome yeah what other questions
do we have
can I kick off a dag based on time of
day or from a cloud function yes I think
so
from that day for sure and if I'm a car
function yes that's one thing I want to
say the way how why we decide to host L
flow web server in this way you know
hosting in GAE and also pro hockey about
how ap gives you two things one is that
our web UI is publicly accessible but
with the security protection in front
from cloud function we have in fact we
have a tutorial on the our cloud talk
website that talks about how you can
trigger a dag execution whatever it is
that G says file change no so it works
like you know you have a G says change
your triggers yourself call and that GCF
a call makes an HTTP POST request to the
composing environment and that it starts
with that excuse perfect perfect maybe I
have some data learning in GCS and then
I want to import that into bigquery and
then do something with it from there
right also I just want to tie that with
the templating things we have discussed
so with external like HTTP Doug
triggering you can also send out long
parameters and or configuration values
those who are getting instantiated
together with each diagram that's
awesome yeah really cool and then really
quick quickly with the kubernetes pod
operator is it possible to startup the
cluster and then shut it down
when the sensor recognizes that the task
is complete wow that sounds a lot of
work I would say yes you can do it but
then you know you have to really study a
you know a container and that actually
talk to GK's service ok you save all
that trouble for you we have this GK
cluster operators that allows you just
easy to just create and delete or update
the GK classes form call a composer
excellent yeah very cool
well thank you for joining us at Google
cloud on air with new live webinars
every Tuesday we hope you have a great
day and we hope you enjoy working with
clock composer
[Music]